Suppose our goal was to pull out the
reddish pixels, so here's one example.
All right?
So let's suppose we filter this, and
we say, we're going to pull out all
the pixels where the red value can be
anything at all, the green has to be
low and the, the blue has to be low.
What do you get?
All right?
Well, you'll see that you get
bunch of stuff where like, look.
Here's a green value, that's dark green,
which is perfectly reasonable because it
might not have very much red at all, but
it has got, you know,
a certain amount of green.
Suppose well,
I want it to be even more red.
Okay?
So you might say well,
let me require that the green and
the blue be even more, me be lower.
You know,
you start to see that you've lost,
first of all you've got these edges
here, these pixels on the thing, and
you've lost some of the red pixels
that you wanted in the, in the apple.
And basically,
it's kind of hard if you're building,
these are essentially box filters,
right there.
There's certain range in red,
certain in green, certain range in blue.
And it would be hard to build a box
filter that pulled out all your red,
your red apples.
And the reason for this,
and we've seen this before,
is that, here we're plotting
three different shades of the,
three different intensities
of sort of the same green.
In the RGB space, right, so in,
in a nice sort of green in the middle,
we get this nice separation
between these values.
But as things get darker, they get
closer, and as they get brighter,
they get closer.
Why is it as they get
darker they get closer and
if they get brighter they get closer?
Remember that cube, right?
So as I get closer to white, right?
The I, I have no choice, but
to sort of get closer in RGB space, and
as I get closer to black I have
no choice, but to get closer.
So to try to do this separation in
RGB space is kind of difficult.